good morning Hank it's 2:30 so back in
August of 2009 somebody started a tumblr
called Obama is literally Hitler which
satirized all the comparisons between
Barack Obama and the leader of the Third
Reich Hitler analogies have a long
history the phrase reductio ad Hitler em
was coined way back in 1951 to describe
arguments that rely on comparing other
people's position to that of the Nazis
or Hitler and even before Hitler was
literally the worst other people were
like one common uber villain was the
pharaoh from the Hebrew Bible's book of
Exodus during the American Civil War
abolitionists sometimes called
slaveholders Pharaoh's and southerners
sometimes called Abraham Lincoln a
modern pharaoh but these days we have
Hitler and the Nazis too compared to
everyone and everything on social media
we read that Hillary Clinton is like
Hitler or Donald Trump or Ted Cruz or
Bernie Sanders also an actual candidate
for president compared to contemporary
United States to Nazi Germany all of
this isn't just inaccurate it's
counterproductive for one thing hearing
your preferred candidate compared to
Hitler doesn't make you less likely to
vote for them you're just repulsed by
the analogy not least because it implies
that you are a Nazi but for another the
analogy imagines that something is
terribly terribly wrong with the United
States like 1930s Germany wrong and
that's just not true the US economy has
grown each of the last six years
unemployment has dropped throughout the
2010s crime is down ninety percent of
Americans have health insurance the
highest rate since the 1970s the United
States is not in some Morgul parents now
of course the u.s. does have big
problems Americans have too much student
loan debt for instance high income
inequality is hindering growth our
health care system is way too expensive
and not particularly effective we
desperately need comprehensive
immigration reform and we still have a
very high violent crime rate compared to
other rich nations but we've always had
big problems like when we talk about
making America great again or reigniting
the American dream when exactly was this
Golden Age were harkening back to was it
200 years ago when the vast majority of
people couldn't vote because they
weren't land owning white males was it a
hundred years ago when most women
couldn't vote fifty years ago when
interracial marriage was still illegal
and half the country or was the American
Golden Age in like 1985 when
unemployment was higher than it is today
median household income was lower and
you were more than twice as likely to be
murdered plus there was no snapchat
I feel like this imagining of a past
that never existed furthers the notion
that the you
is facing some unprecedented danger that
only candidate X or Y can solve and then
when politics focuses on name-calling
rather than policy it becomes really
hard to have a discussion because when
you call my candidate an idiot or a
loser or a cheat you're calling into
question my whole future in a way it
feels like you're calling me those
things which makes me want to remove
myself from the conversation long before
we get to the nuances of safe
immigration reform rataxes policy all
the presidential candidates have done
this sort of name-calling but i don't
want to create a false equivalence here
donald trump does it by far the most
like here's just a sampling of trump's
insults liar choker disloyal a low-life
crazy dishonest reckless a hypocrite and
a soft weak little baby and that's just
some of the things he said about ted
cruz that i can repeat in a vlogbrothers
video now putting aside the accuracy of
those insults I mean I quite like little
babies but I've seen very little
evidence to indicate that Ted Cruz is
one I think insults hurt American
political life which in turn makes our
government less effective regardless of
where our political leaders sit on the
ideological spectrum and I really hope
that eventually in this election cycle
we can find ways to avoid insults and
instead focus on what government should
do and how so Hank you and I are gonna
start trying to do that next Tuesday I'm
gonna take a look at the Republican
candidates tax plans but first Hank on
Friday you're gonna take a look at the
tax plans put forth by the Democratic
candidates I will see you then
here's to civil discourse